let's talk about this I want to bring in
former acting Homeland Security
secretary Chad Wolfe you and I have been
perched since before last hour watching
the president what is your first take on
his first words as president
at the border with Mexico
well I thought overall Harris the speech
was a little a little confusing it was
Meandering and in places contradictory
it was clear that the president really
wasn't sure what he was talking about he
talked about a number of different
programs that weren't accurate he talked
about gang violence in Central America
as a basis to claim Asylum that's not
true under U.S law I think that's
important he talked about continuing to
process more illegal aliens into the
country instead of actually solving the
problem he talked about Parole in the
Venezuelan program that started back in
October and yes we may see fewer
Venezuelans at the border but guess what
the numbers continue to increase month
after month after month it's just
different populations and so applying
this parole program which I would say is
is not lawful to other populations it's
still not going to solve the problem at
the end of the day and then of course he
concluded with title 42 yeah this is an
authority that he has said he doesn't
like that they are fighting in in front
of the Supreme Court yet he's going to
extend title 42. so it's very unclear
what the strategy is what the long-term
strategy is uh for for the Border I
think that that speech raised more
questions uh than answers how could it
not
situation on his own and the two people
that that he put in charge have been so
woefully incompetent that it's it's
almost laughable and one of them he gave
a setup to the uh Homeland secretary
mayorkas well the you know everybody's
waiting to talk to him no I I don't
think anybody is and the vice president
Kamala Harris I mean what has she done
as the borders off what a mess so you
you extend title 42 which he says he
doesn't like did he tell us why he
doesn't like it did he tell us what he'd
like to see in its place does he know
the difference between titles eight and
nine
well no I don't think he does he again I
think what they what it shows you is
that there is no comprehensive plan for
that border they do not have a border
security strategy they have a title 42
strategy by his own admission will go
away this year so then what's the
strategy after that why I don't
understand why they are now simply
trying to come up with a strategy that
they've known they've been in this this
problem for over 24 or about 24 months
now and yet this feels like a a solution
here at the last minute that they've
come up with in trying to figure that
out now Harris you know he also
mentioned Congress and I've got to come
back to this because this is a point
that I think the viewers need to really
understand he keeps talking about
Republicans or or members of Congress
won't help what they are advocating for
is amnesty uh what he put forward at the
beginning of his administration of
course then he mentioned uh Senator
Cinema and Senator Tillis they are
talking about amnesty for three million
people
someone needs to explain to me and
others on how amnesty equals border
security the two have nothing to do with
one another and yet they are conflating
the issue and somehow trying to convince
the American people that if you give
amnesty to three million people who have
been here for years and years and years
that somehow that's going to stop 230
000 uh people coming here every month
it's disingenuous it's dishonest and I I
get fired up over that because it's not
it's not going to solve the issue well
it's reflexively what a politician would
do point the finger to the other side
the problem is that the finger needs to
go right in in his own chest I mean it
feels like 24 months ago because it was
24 months ago that he flipped the switch
on Trump error policies and look no one
is saying that they were perfect and
that they were solving every problem but
we have so many more people in this
country that we would have to hand
amnesty to at some point because the
floodgates have been open for those two
years
well that's exactly right you can talk
about all these different programs that
they're looking at or you can actually
just go back to what works and obviously
there's a number of programs that we put
in place during the Trump Administration
but we also built on programs from
previous administrations that also
worked so you don't need to reinvent the
wheel you can just go back to what
actually works and then to talk about
this parole program it's interesting
because when you parole individuals into
the country you are not actually
adjudicating any type of Asylum claim
you are actually admitting that they
have no basis for Asylum so therefore
you have to parole them in otherwise
they would go through the Asylum system
and they would grant their their
protections through that through that
process so the Biden Administration is
admitting that these groups of
individuals whether it's Venezuelans
Cubans Haitians uh have no basis for
Asylum so therefore they have to parole
them into the U.S it's just it's not a
an honest conversation with the American
people I feel like they're trying to
hide the ball in many circumstances here
you feel that way because they are that
that is that is a sleight of hand that
that you've just caught in mid-game and
it doesn't solve any of our problems
when you stand at the border and you
know this Chad when you stand there and
you see our men and women pulling little
ones families out of the water because
that current is so vicious on the Rio
Grande and some of them don't make it
how does anything that the president
said today address any of that and then
our guys taking their own lives
committing suicide with the border
patrol because it's all too much didn't
hear that either
Chad Wolfe so great to get to get
started with you this hour of
outnumbered I appreciate your time thank
you very much
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 p.m Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights